I run into a certain type of article
fairly often usually linked to from
Twitter or reddit that has started to
really really bother me here's an
example Emilia Clarke says Ron Howard
saved solo and praises Kathleen Kennedy
for making the change it's an
interesting attention-grabbing headline
let's check out the article the first
paragraph provides a little context for
why her opinion on these things might be
relevant so far so good but the second
paragraph is where we get a clue that
something might be off here we learn she
said these things in an interview with
Vanity Fair the following eight
paragraphs most of the article are
copied and pasted quotes from the Vanity
Fair piece a summary of what she said or
information you could find in the Vanity
Fair article there's little to no
editorial ization
this whole article essentially just mind
some quotes from another publication
interview adds an ouch mentions when
solo premieres and then slaps an
attention-grabbing clickbait a headline
on top of it okay Thomas you might say
that's just one low effort article is
headline mining really a big issue get
this the playlist in the space of two
days posted not one not two but three
such articles that mine various quotes
and headlines from the same Vanity Fair
piece look at the first sentence on this
one Amelia Clark's Vanity Fair profile
is the gift that keeps on giving no
kidding and this isn't an isolated case
this article on indieWIRE does the exact
same thing the playlist does with the
same Vanity Fair article the added value
is little to none these types of
articles often frustrate me because as
soon as I click on the link and realize
this is just an article quoting another
article I immediately just want to read
the original but there's even sometimes
dark pattern design implemented here a
prominently displayed link labeled read
more with a related headline stands out
making me think it might be directing me
towards the source the actual source is
the fourth link in the article the first
three links all take you to more
indieWIRE content more than once I've
accidentally clicked on one of these
links thinking it will take me to the
source only to find myself looking at
another article by the same publication
so at this point as the reader all
is to read the original interview of the
statement was in but I've already given
two page views to a publication for
content that isn't theirs maybe you
don't share my frustration maybe you
don't have time to read a long Vanity
Fair profile on Amelia Clark but you're
glad somebody else is reading it and
putting the most interesting pieces into
an article that you can read in two
minutes
I dislike these articles but I don't
want to strawman my opponent so let me
make the best case I can for why
headline mining might be a good thing I
didn't even bother reading this box
article that was basically a review of
The Rolling Stones recent Johnny Depp
profile but I did find out about and
read The Rolling Stones article because
of it in a way the headline mining
article can almost act as an ad or
promotion for the larger article so
these smaller articles might get the
attention of people who never would have
read the full piece smart news
publications will do this with their own
interviews if something significant is
set sometimes a quote will itself become
a news event and it makes sense for
other news outlets to report on it
ideally I think these reports should add
commentary context or discussion to the
report rather than just simply
summarizing the contents of the
interview or adding a goofy quip here's
an example of this type of article done
well this is from birth movies death
calm and it's essentially just reporting
on something the site Collider reported
in an article but they are upfront in
the headline about what they're doing
they add context that's valuable
then they clearly encourage the viewer
to read the Collider article multiple
times making the link to the original
piece easy to find this is how I think
it should be done if it must be done but
I'm not here to criticize the articles
that do this right let's look at a few
more examples here's one about some
things that hero Mirai said in an
interview with Variety about the music
video this is America the article
provides a small paragraph of context
about who Mirai is cites the variety
interview as the source and then
straight up copies verbatim several
questions and answers from the article
that's it and headline mining doesn't
just happen to long form written
interviews this article on indieWIRE
mine's a headline from a Jimmy Kimmel
video
now to be clear I'm not claiming this
practice is copyright infringement or
plagiarism fair use laws might protect
some of these articles were to come up
in court but there are other reasons why
headline mining isn't great first it
often robs the statement that's being
highlighted of its context within the
interview especially with particularly
controversial things removing a
statement from its context may change
how it's perceived secondly headline
mining steals attention from the
journalists who are doing the actual
work of going and getting the interview
this trend of news reporting other news
distances the reader further and further
from the original source which in an era
where we all have to be mindful of the
validity of a piece of news makes that
more difficult look at this piece from
the rap it isn't even summarizing or
quoting a piece of a larger interview
it's merely restating the original
article by Entertainment Weekly I also
wouldn't be concerned about this trend
if I saw it rarely but there are sites
out there that exist almost entirely off
of this type of content these article to
work because turning a long-form
interview from podcast or video into a
clickbait easy to consume headline makes
it more shareable on social media
there's no downside to publishers for
using this practice even if you're
frustrated by articles like this and
choose to read the original source once
you click on a link that's shared it
doesn't matter to the site if you go on
to read the original source or not they
already have you for what they want you
for a page view that they can serve ads
onto so if you're like me and don't like
these articles you can do a few things
to help promote the hard-working
journalists that are actually doing
interviews and creating a reporting
content first you can try to avoid sites
that practice this regularly some sites
are much worse offenders than others but
the best thing I think you can do is to
not share these types of articles if you
want to share what someone said about
something share the quote and a link to
the original article direct people's
attention to the source not a website
leeching off the source for page views
ultimately I'm not saying sites
shouldn't
or on content from other sites but when
they do they should be as upfront about
it as possible add additional commentary
for context and make it as easy as
possible for the reader to find the
original source but what do you think is
this a real problem or just a mildly
annoying trend or do you think this
practice is actually beneficial in some
way let's discuss it in the comments
this video is sponsored by Nord bpn I'm
extremely excited to have them as a
sponsor because I've been a paying
customer of Nord VPN for over a year and
I can personally recommend their service
to anyone looking for a VPN Nord VPN
encrypts and hides your internet
activity from anyone that might be
trying to snoop like your ISP
advertisers or the government in the
United States were privileged enough
that if we don't like a news
publications practices online like
headline mining for instance we can
easily find other new sites to choose
from but in some countries like China
thanks to censorship the choice of news
is very limited and residents have to
use a VPN like Nord VPN to access the
free and open Internet and uncensored
news Nord VPN is the most user-friendly
VPN I've ever used just choose from one
of the superfast servers in over 61
countries and you're instantly secured
and protected on up to six devices at
once including your phone nor VPN is
offering my viewers seventy seven
percent off three year plans just go to
Nord VPN comm slash Thomas flight well
click on the link in the description to
sign up and start protecting yourself
that's Nord VPN comm slash Thomas flight
and use the code thomas fly to checkout
to get started today
[Music]